hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Orcs Must Die - okay I'm here
with Tom hi say hi Tom
I said hi say hi again hello hello okay
anyway oh oh you guys don't even know I
just upgraded my spike traps oh no I was
gonna be banging you and your spikes
traps yeah yeah I haven't done it before
I'm gonna have the trap reset trinket Oh
what do I have to have to try to reset
trigger active in my it has a passive
and active ability
yeah but the healing thing only worked
when you had it like selected no traps
reset faster if you have it and then if
you activate it it resets all of them
for mana okay good alright that this oh
it's gonna be bangin that's like my new
catchphrase
say it with me down oh you know it's
gonna be banging really say it this is
gonna be banging say say it better no
everybody else who's listening say oh
it's gonna be banging yeah I got that
from someone I was talking to in the
knock screw it's been stuck in my head
ever since are you done yet okay I'm
done okay continue
oh there's gonna be banging was that
help menu help
I need more skulls playback he didn't
even check to see if I was breathing huh
he grabbed my crossbow and blade stuff
and left me there lingering at the edge
of consciousness I could have sworn I
heard him giggle
when I felt the magic die I knew what
he'd done he'd saved the world but he
hadn't understood the cost droughts
starvation misery just as bad as the orc
mobs had inflicted I was still the
oldest living war mage with the last of
my power I could open one small she was
flawed I knew that but together my two
ex apprentices had the potential to be
story that's a big map oh wait there's
another door over here and it's right
next to the exit so they are they forced
to loot okay they're forced to live here
no stealing really really wish I had
that swinging trap yeah we'll get it
later all right so I got I gotta get
this crap out of here I got the thingy
that reduce Amana a lot once again I
forgot to get a spell so I'm an idiot
whoops uh well it doesn't matter all
that matters is the spike trap and I
guess I'll get a trap just to spend
money okay good enough all right so do
we want to bottle the choices we want to
bottleneck them here or do we want to
start over there where the other door is
and then go if we wanted to get the
part-time we'd have to go over there
right so I guess yeah why don't you go
over there and I'll stay back here yeah
with my spike traps it works better if I
have a long hallway anyway okay okay all
right I mean you can come over here when
they start no I'll stay here
oh he's gonna be back ready to go
alrighty yep I'm ready to spike traps
uh hey okay I'm ready
all right come on we gotta make that far
time although these little ones didn't
even set off my spike traps what that
what's going on nothing
the little ones are too fast for them ah
no done it's done done you better hey I
had them charms I've done it ducks don't
like this
Hey hahaha mine a new door is opening ah
that sucks I guess I'll watch this one I
told Stabbin time
freakin matter they are coming
I don't even have my windmill what is
wrong with me on minutes I'm gonna be
the worst ever this time it's gonna be
the worst I'm going over there
goodbye it what what ah stupid thing all
right it's okay you know what I'm a sell
dough once I head back there
junk Greek city
you still have your few traps nope No
why not shut up I thought out its that's
stupid shut your face
shut up I'm gonna win this with spike
traps just you watch don't even have my
window
okay yeah see ah not so bad and not so
bad
mine
a headshot come on that shot him
oh crap where are they
I guess they're coming down the long
haul
boy
Oh oh yeah now I'll get a hug in the
front and no one got stuck up on the
ridge
you aren't kidding about this headshot
its benefit yeah
I can I can basically stun up
forever if I can ever hit him there
cup got unleash gotta be the part
[Applause]
any day there we go see easy
if you say so
not even a pitiful
oh boy
got ogres come on but ogre focus coming
up
autumn
these are
are we doing
they wouldn't be able to get through if
we had some sticky charge [ __ ] shut your
face we don't have it so we just got to
make do
you got you're not gonna be you're not
gonna be making fun of me with whole
areas like mine if you say so
oh crap I hate those things I think you
do have to have
oh well that's
more fun
the barricades don't
well that's because you're standing on
him sorry they aim their guns at you
start their arrows
so bad sure but it's all my chops those
combos my coins you can put a spike drop
right here I suppose Thanks I don't want
to take up your space
all right
hey the frying pan into my fire
party
[Applause]
see see what 7:00 to 7:00 now all lined
up yes spike beautiful thing
let me see good we're not I'm gonna have
to worry about that area that's all over
place
oh crap where they coming from I don't
know
that's a lot of dead
you ever figure out where these orcs
came from
the orc world yeah I don't know where
to work on coming out a lot o our
favorites
could be like that uh that creature from
Dragon Age oh that's yeah
and again I never really got those
the brood mother's oh wait no yeah
actually this knocking things how did
you toss them around quite a bit
yeah they do how's it damage
get down but no standing on it no
sundown it's still there it's gonna
repair itself well I don't have the self
repair upgrade yet but there is one
should we go I mean knock yeah go yeah
okay
three time that's actually getting
locked up pretty good
I keep forgetting I can charge this
weapon and I wish I could charge my
weapon
but you already have the stunning good
that and charm on the same weapon Oh cup
got it
and Biddy they are smashing up those
variants
well they're not supposed to it's when
they're hitting each other they they
kind of cleave it oh okay yeah
this is working kinda yeah
got through my bike traps oh no past
ones by one weakness
come back kobold i think they're
pronounced Cobalts kobold
almost got it done
about time shut up
I can't wait go home here all right what
did I do
I was gonna block it so that they can
only come this way oh well one before it
yeah I was gonna put one right here and
now you got a spike trap here what's
wrong here but they're gonna come only
this way
but now I can
they still got it Oh God
- lost count again
Oh Archie
that's not so bad
especially when he's done them yeah well
I mean I got so much madam
look at em all go flying yeah I guess
maybe this balance
yeah
I guess the gospel was kind of overtime
okay last round - round where do you
want me sell this one I guess you can
keep it it worked out pretty well
- funnel they let you put your things
there
okay there we go ready
other hallo I guess
they blow up those barricades
yeah they better not
feel free
Sooni yet
maybe your traps gonna baby could be I
don't know how
Oh
much hazy if I actually had good traps
maybe we would have done well oh yeah
five skulls that's great
yeah I never use it alright anyway
that's all the time we got for this
episode thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always we'll see you in
the next video bye bye bye